all right
okay lee do you ready to go okay great
thank you
okay good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's
meeting of the executive item one
is attendances i'm not aware of any
apologies have we received any
um into democratic services at all not
to me leader
thank you okay item two is questions
from
members of the public and none have been
received
item three is declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
in any items on the agenda
no okay item
and foreign have been referred um
so item five then first substantive
item is the all age travel assistance
policy i will come to councillor heinz
first and then to council a carter if
that's okay thanks
thank you uh leader so um this
item has been um two executive very
recently
um and it has been discussed in
council so i don't propose to say um
too much um in addition to that really
but i am quite happy to
answer um any questions um and
i move the report thank you
thank you councillor carter anything to
add just what kath says that
um happy to answer questions thank you
okay are there any questions or comments
from
members of the executive cognizant that
we have
um had this here before and obviously
last week
no um sorry i'm going to
um just just break up
moving this paper and i can get out to
questions counselor morgan did you want
to declare
an interest sorry thank you leader sorry
you missed my hand going up
um you were being very efficient to the
uh um agenda
um i just don't agenda item nine there's
a point on um
some of the um funding that's been
requested
um and around um heat pumps and i just
just to
declare a slight interest in that the
company i work for is air source heat
pumping as part of its business model
thank you okay thanks councillor morgan
i actually don't know the answer to
whether people who aren't members of the
executive
need to declare an interest or not um
but that's something that we should
clarify for future
for future meetings because obviously we
won't be voting on it but thanks for
um making us aware regardless so
apologies for that um are there any
questions or comments
more broadly than the executive
no okay the recommendations are as set
out
in the report can they be agreed please
thank you item six is
um fair price for um for care and could
i ask councillor harding you to move
items 6a
and 6b together if that is okay please
yes thank you leader um
uh each year trafford council goes
through a consultation on the fair price
for care
for social care as to the rates that we
pay for
nursing and residential beds and also
the hourly rate that we pay
our home care providers the reports are
for noting
a consultation has taken place with
three options on each of the
um on the papers really so it is for
noting i think what is really important
to say
um that this council puts on record
to recognize all the incredible work
that the social care sector have played
throughout this pandemic really um i
want to thank the care homes for the
creativity
in which they have managed um caring for
our most vulnerable
we can only begin to imagine some of the
issues they have had to deal with
and the trauma that they will face as as
we come out of this so i do think it's
really important
that we we minute that really our thanks
for the social care sector
so as i said really um this is part of
our continuing work with the unison
ethical care charter as we continue to
embed this
over the next couple of years we knew
that we would have to be
in a staged approach and also that we
are
waiting and we continue to wait as most
local authorities do
on more national guidance on a green
paper and a fairer funding formula for
social care so as i say both papers are
for noting
i think to to note that we now have the
minimum bed rate
for residential five seven one seven six
and um six three nine fifteen for
nursing
and an uplift on our hourly rate for
home care as we continue to do the
transformation work on home care
which is actually starting to pay
dividends as we look to develop a more
patch-based and neighborhood-based model
and all of this
is about making sure that we support our
residents to live
safely and independently at home so
thank you to
um to diane eaton and karen artmed for
all the work that's gone into these
reports
i know it's never easy and we've had a
couple of
um comments from some providers and some
very positive reports from gmb
union so um we we will continue to work
to support the sector
but the reports are to be noted and
approved by the executive
thank you council harding and certainly
echo um
thanks that you that you set out at the
beginning of your
contribution um so the um
papers 6a and 6b are being taken
together are there any questions or
comments on either paper from members of
the executive
no any questions or comments more widely
okay so taking item 6a and 6b together
the recommendations being set out in
both
of the reports um can they be approved
please
um item seven is progress review
recovery update since october 2020
council of freeman
please thank you leader this is the
second recovery update
for 2020 2021 and provides a summary of
performance
from the first of october the 31st of
december 2020
the recovery plan supports the delivery
of the corporate plan
and the strategic priorities and
continues to be delivered
at pace governance is strong
with the recovery coordination group
meeting twice a week
the highlighting of reports which are
prepared along with risk logs and a
monthly pandemic plan
the trafford partnership board meets on
a quarterly basis
their immediate recovery activity
concentrates on the next two years
whilst ensuring the work transitions
into a longer term
10-year plan for trafford learning from
our covid experience
from the lockdowns and the demands of
covid19 response
we continue to monitor the impacts to
the council resource
and staff welfare therefore we have
established a separate thematic group
purely focused on resourcing there are
many achievements outlined in the report
and the slide deck some of which i'd
like the technology to highlight
tonight and some of which were spoken
about
in the budget speech last week 1385
vulnerable children visits took place
face to face in december to ensure that
our vulnerable children are safe and
well
all of our looked after children
returned to school
we successfully launched urgent and
emergency care uec by
appointment program nhs111 talk before
you walk
we resurrected trafford cancer patient
partnerships achieving pre-covered 19
levels
of two-week wait times for g from gp
referral to appointment
we appointed a domestic abuse
coordinator we submitted the application
of
520k from the national leisure recovery
fund to support the ongoing work
to reopen leisure centres we received a
635k
homelessness prevention grant which is
higher than expected
businesses have received the new one-off
lockdown grant combined value at 4.7
million
we progressed and are progressing a
number of initiatives to support digital
inclusion including
a device loan scheme operating out of
the libraries grants to vcsc
organizations
and the launch of the leaders laptop for
learners campaign which has been
extremely successful
we've delivered an enhanced health and
wellbeing of offer for our staff
including
monthly team talk sessions for staff
hosted by our mental health
first aiders we have communicated a
strong
working from home message to all of our
staff
there continues to be a number of
challenges as we are in the third
lockdown
including considering the implications
that could occur
should multiple ways of the pandemic
continue to be experienced
and consider the need to consider the
disproportionate
impact on the community and ensuring
that we develop
and build a recovery strategy from our
plan which is inclusive and relevant
to our residents and to our businesses a
number of next steps are outlined in the
report which include
reviewing the recovery plan following
any changes to the corporate plan
strategic priorities
and the kind of council we want to be
ensuring the recovery plan
includes digital skills green space
carbon neutrality
and sustainability across all themes and
action plans
ensuring that inclusion is central to
the recovery plan
and inherent in everything that we do
and aligning current strategies and
actions underway to the recovery
programme
including the one-year poverty strategy
the fact that the census is taking place
and the fact we're now facing that local
elections
and we will continue to strive hard on
recovery and we'll bring a further
report
later this year to the executive and
i'll just point out a full glossary of
all the terms used in the report is
provided at appendix one
and i'm asking for the executive to note
the report
thank you leader
thank you councillor freeman any
questions or comments from members of
the executive
any questions or comments more widely
counselor copings please thank you
leader i'll i'll just be brief
um sorry my mind's gone like that um yes
thank you tim a useful update and and
we're making good progress
um there's some discussion in there of
the cycle lanes on the a56 which is part
of i suppose the legacy that we
should be coming out of this crisis with
so part of the recovery
and unfortunately it seems to be going
backwards more roughly than it is going
forwards we've had
two lots of ballards taken out recently
and disturbingly only after they were
raised issues were raised by green
cancers
i'm just wondering is there an update on
what will now be going in are we
sticking with basically the same plan
but moving things slightly
um and i suppose some reassurances that
um what goes in will meet the standards
first time around
rather than being up to actually you
know cancers and people to go and take
photos and
and measure things up on the road which
isn't really a safe or
or sustainable way to go on thanks thank
you councillor cobbins if it's okay with
council agreement i'll answer that one
actually
um i don't particularly care for the
fact that this is a public meeting when
i say that we have been
consistently let down by
our partners amy on some of the
sustainable transport activities not
only
related to the a56 and it would be
perfectly reasonable i think for me to
to highlight that tonight some of the
issues are
um very well documented and where there
are
schemes being implemented they should of
course comply
with the regulations around distance
from the curb etc etc and that is our
expectation
um clearly the um
the issue not only pertains to the
distance the width of the cycle lane but
also
in particular where they place an inside
bollard
um having not told us that they plan to
do so and i am reassured
um now by some changes made to
governance arrangements in terms of the
implementation
of both the short term
active travel emergency funding schemes
but also the
active travel mares transport schemes
more widely around sign off and
engineering meetings that will mean that
we do
our best to um avoid such issues in the
future but clearly where there are
there are issues you know we we
obviously want people to
make us aware of that and in terms of
the
um particulars around the a56 scheme it
does remain broadly us set out when
we last provided an update on our more
medium and long term planning
for the a56 there is
a meeting due to go in the diary shortly
with myself the chief executive and
others to look
in detail at that particular scheme but
certainly the
um proposals that were brought forward
um earlier this year
around replacing the cones with ones etc
etc is still the
broad principles that we're working to
um
councillor evans
thank you thank you chair just
potentially not the right form but it's
not really clear
and given the errors that have been made
by
uh our partner it just seems odd
and we shared those errors and our
feelings towards our partner with
gm more widely because they have they
not just been appointed
across gm to deliver similar
um infrastructure
such as charging points et cetera it
seems
odd that we seem to have had such a bad
experience
and yeah they're landing massive
contracts
so it's a fair point i think we
obviously cannot directly prejudice any
sort of procurement process that goes
ahead it's fair to say that i have
raised
eyebrows um at some of the
um some of the decisions that have been
made but clearly
it would be um inappropriate to
consider that i would have a veto
outside of a procurement process or that
anybody else
from trafford wood i think that they
will they will learn as this council has
had to
um over a number of years that robux
client management
is very important when working on any
scheme
such as this that's not just singling
out the provider in question that is
about saying that there
are um clear clear implications if you
don't have a robust client management
process in place and
also you need to um keep particularly
close eye when embarking on
new projects and in particular in the
case of of the emergency active travel
schemes
um projects where time is very much of
the essence and perhaps the
um the approach you know if i could have
my time again for the past
12 months the one thing that i would be
keenest to
look at and change the way that we went
about it was not necessarily the schemes
that we chose but the way in which they
have been
implemented so there is there is clearly
a need i think
both for ourselves and gm to ensure that
robust
monitoring and oversight moving forward
as i said earlier we have changed
um some of our processes to make sure
that we have that locally moving forward
and certainly i'm sure that um all
members
will be keen to make sure that greater
manchester do the same
um councillor jerome please
thanks i think there will be a
measurement of footfall in both our sail
waterside and trafford town hall
buildings
is that to kind of a serious look at our
property portfolio
and what we might be needing in the
future
council the freedom do you want me to
carry on yeah
so um you'll be aware councillor jerome
that there was some controversy
um for various reasons around an initial
line in the budget proposals that talked
about the
council's estate moving forward but
specifically i think it is prudent
to look to rationalize the state um in
terms of
council offices at the moment given the
changing working practices that we've
seen over the past 12 months so in
particular
one of the things that we have here
marked as a possibility
was whether we could release a floor of
sail waterside and look to generate some
rental income
from that as a result of colleagues
working from home or
dividing their time between home-based
working and office-based working
clearly that has positive implications
for work-life balance
for sustainable environmental practice
in terms of reducing car
journeys and similarly at the town hall
we
we not yet fully aware of what i
returned to anything like normal
in terms of the future normal will look
like but it would strike me that there
may be opportunities for us to look to
free up some space not for sale and it's
very important um
to clarify that but for the potential
lease
or sharing of buildings with partners um
clearly we successfully moved the ccg
into the town hall
um last year or the year before and
there may be opportunities
to um you know through initiatives like
that
to allow us to engage in even closer
partnership working so
so it's not a definitive we absolutely
will be releasing space but it's
certainly an ambition it's certainly
part of the 220
thousand pounds i'm testing myself now
that we um
set up on the estate's review as part
of the budget as an income generation
figure
and certainly an element of that
pertains specifically to
sail waterside and the possibility of um
renting out
some of the some of the floor space
there should we be able to do so within
the terms of the arrangement that we
have
with the operator there um
i'm not seeing any other hands raised
unless councillor coggins are you
looking to come back in or is that
what we what we are um supposed to call
a legacy hand i think
it's a legacy hand i'll take it that's
that's fine
um so i'm not seeing any further
questions or
comments so the recommendations are set
out on the report can that be
can they be agreed please
thank you and councillor freeman i'm
back to you with the trafford inclusive
economy recovery plan and transition
preparedness update
please thank you leader um the kovid 19
pandemic is unprecedented and is having
an adverse impact on residents
businesses
and the economy as a whole the trafford
inclusive economy recovery plan
at appendix 1 has been prepared to
provide the strategy for the delivery of
economic recovery and a more inclusive
economy in trafford
you will note from the paper the
national greater manchester and trafford
effects of the pandemic
and that traffic has seen the largest
rising claimant counts across gm
at 117 since the onset of clovid
the traffic inclusive economy recovery
plan the plan
contributes to the council's wider
corporate recovery plan
and forms an important element of the
work of the inclusive economy board
and the traffic partnership the plan has
not only been set in the context of
meeting key issues facing the borough
but also to be complementary to the work
of the greater manchester local
enterprise partnership economic vision
and build back better priorities which
sets
out sets out to create a better
opportunity
for a strong and successful recovery the
plan is a live document and it may be
amended over time as circumstances
change
and the issues arise meeting the
challenges caused by the clothing
pandemic and ensuring an effective
recovery
will not be easy and will require a
strong partnership approach to tackle
the issues
facing the local economy through to
recovery and beyond
appendix 1 gives details of the
inclusive economy recovery plan
the plan covers the following themes
business support and sustainable job
creation
transition preparedness green economy
and sustainable job creation
sustainable jobs and skills growth for
local residents
inward investment and sustainable job
creation
funding and growth strategic sites
development and job creation
improved town centers for residents and
businesses and increased visitor economy
within the plan the specific actions
required to support the council's
objectives
for economic recovery and delivery of a
more inclusive traffic economy
are identified alongside the time scales
for implementation
and the relationship to the council's
corporate plan priorities
turning to the transition preparedness
plan the council has tried
to best future proof against the effects
of brexit
and the uk transition from the eu the
traffic brexit impact assessment of
february 2019
was completed to identify the potential
implications on the local economy
and following the recommendations
contained in the assessment which were
endorsed by the executive
last february to on february 2019
an internal transition impact group was
established to take a cross-council
proactive
and coordinated approach in identifying
the effects on service delivery
and the potential mitigation measures
required the group contains
offices from strategic growth legal
adult and children service social
services regulatory services
the safer traffic partnership education
commissioning
the one traffic partnership hr
communications the ccg and information
governance
and that group is also attended by my
executive
fellow executive members for housing
regeneration finance the investment in
communities and partnerships
a high level transition preparedness
plan identifying the key priorities and
issues for each
service area has been produced by the
group as a focus four activity going
forward which is that appendix
ii the preparedness plan is a
combination of actions and issues that
are monitored and reviewed by the group
on a regular basis
the gmca has re-established his
preparedness group
which comprises members from the 10
local authorities
and key stakeholders including the gm
growth hub
child transport the creator manchester
the nhs highways england manchester
airport greater manchester police
and the ministry of housing communities
and local government
the work of this group has provided an
overarching strategic framework
to which travelers transition
preparedness plan is complementary
under the trade and cooperation
agreement tariff and quota free trade
between the uk and eu will continue
as part of a bilateral trade agreement
however it is important to note
that there are certain issues around
their extra framework rules of origin
northern ireland status and additional
administrative requirements
requirements bureaucracy that are likely
to have a direct effect on business for
example
businesses must show where their goods
were made where the components in those
products cut in from
to determine whether tariffs are levied
on goods into the eu
also british exporters must register to
pay vat in eu countries
they're exporting to in addition the
ending of the free movement of people
from the eu to the uk
could have an impact on recruitment and
meeting skills gaps
in lies of the above and the ongoing
effects of the kobe crisis a review of
the practical impact assessment will be
commissioned
in order to understand the impacts of
the trade agreement on local businesses
residents and the economy the review
will be funded from the brexit
preparedness grant and is received by
the council
any negative impacts on council service
delivery will also be covered
linked to the to the issues identified
in the transition preparedness plan
in addition the review will also be set
in the context of covid and its effects
on business
unemployment and the economy and a
further report will be taken to the
executive
once this review has been completed why
the corporate links
the trafford inclusive economy recovery
plan is consistent with the council's
corporate plan
and the council's other policies and
strategies including the poverty
strategy and the carbon neutral action
plan
the plan also sits under and it's a key
element in the delivery of the corporate
recovery strategy at a gm level it will
support the growth ambitions
articulated in the gm strategy gm
local enterprise partnership economic
division the gm
list lis and the emerging sub-regional
plan
for the nine local uh not the nine gm
local authorities
other options an option would be not to
progress
uh the traffic inclusive economy
recovery plan or to be put
or to prepare a different strategy
however the continued absence
of a clear plan for the delivery of
economic recovery in trafford
will not provide the council with the
strategic approach within which to make
decisions
on the future activity to support its
objectives
priorities uh resources and deliver a
more inclusive economy
the recovery plan has been produced in
consultation with the inclusive economy
board and the exec members
also with the exact members for housing
uh
regeneration communities and partnership
and a full glossary of all the terms
used in the report is attached it's
attached at the rear of the report
executive is asked to approve the
traffic inclusive economy recovery plan
and to provide the strategy for delivery
of economic recovery and a more
inclusive economy
in trafford thank you leader thank you
councillor freeman are there any
questions or comments from
members of the executive
no questions or comments more widely
counselor evans please
thank you chair uh two points and
page uh 173 and 175 so 173 bt between
it which is strategic sites for jobs
etc and 175 improved town centres
um etc this seems to be
stratford's made it onto the list but we
seem to have a glaring
er emission in areas that we are
directly responsible for
and by that i mean the uh missing teeth
that is the grafton center
and the stanford quarter and for that
matter altair
ultrum doesn't get a feature in this
recovery and that town
center i won't allude to what i alluded
to at council
i don't need to because actually it's a
glaring emission of somewhere where we
are
in a in a gonna be in a in a desperate
state and probably
we and we as a counter got full control
and then just moving
on to page 177 which is a
commitment to town centers and
it's the two place plans uh which
sale more and hail the confidence
in the consultations uh has slipped
considerably
on on what's been delivered and are we
sure we're going to get another
consultation in the summer on these two
place plans
i think we've been given up assurance
but it's nothing i'm not actually seeing
it in writing anywhere
and thank you
answer freeman did you want to come back
on those i'm going to ask um
my colleague from house of generation
the place plans to answer that one
um and and in regards to ultragum um
yes yeah i i have to say that the you
know all of our town centers will be
will be taken care of
as part of the second economy recovery
plan we're not you know if the
commitment is the town said yes
strep had got a mention but i think we
all are acutely aware
of this are still of the needs of
ultrasound counselor evans
transfer right yeah i can just
just to reassure you cancer evans there
will be another full consultation
on sale uh more and hail place plans in
the summer
um there was an update given to the um
chair of scrutiny uh before christmas
which should be available on the
uh website for you to read but there
will be a forthcoming consultation in
the summer yes
gonna come back in check yeah sure thank
you councillor wright that's great
appreciate that
councillor freeman a couple of words on
altering them it is our our
name i know stratford's probably up
there without a doubt and that's been
neglected for many a year and nobody
denies that
however two you know two words on old
tree i mean we are acutely aware
we need it in writing what what are we
going to be doing about altering it
frankly and it is staring us in the face
and it's frightening
i think i mean i will i will come in
unless councillor wright is
desperate to do so or councillor freeman
but i just think that we are in danger
here of talking altering them down a
little bit
ultron gum is um obviously a town center
where we hope to continue
the success that we have seen in recent
years and we obviously have a
considerable
interest in altering them that underpins
this administration's
focus and support for altering them if
there was
a phrase that i don't like it is
main town center principal town center
um
it's not something that that i
personally
find favor with as a means of describing
any of our town centres we're committed
to all of our town centres
um stretford plays a particular role not
only because
of the regeneration of the town centre
but because of other assets in the area
such as the civic quarter
um area action plan um and and other
and other local sites i that does not
mean that
that altering and sale ernst at the
villages that you mentioned councillor
evans on aren't a priority
and i don't think that um oshingham not
being named in this
in this document specifically takes away
from the ambitions that we have either
at
altair at the grafton center or at
stanford quarter or indeed
um any of the other assets over which we
have direct control
in altering them there is a there is a
need i think with this and it's not an
unfair challenge to ask why is
them not specifically referenced but to
look at the smokers board that we have
of policy documents decisions taken
and direction of travel set by this
administration that set out the ways in
which we have supported oceanum and will
continue to
do so moving forward i i don't know if
the ward councillors have received
um an invitation yet or even indeed been
briefed on
um some of the plans uh for the stamford
quarter
over the next few months but i think we
will need to reach a point fairly
quickly council evans where they are
shared
more widely if that meeting has taken
place because there are
a number of initiatives that are coming
forward for ocean and town centre in the
next few months that i think will
help us to bring the town centre back to
its former glory and i think that whilst
we cannot be complacent we can be
confident
that if any of our town centers not just
in trafford
but indeed probably across the northwest
um are able to bounce back
resiliently we can have as much faith in
altering them as we can
anywhere else but i can see that
councillor coggins and councillor jerome
jerome have put their hands up um so i
will come to councillor coggins
firstly please i just confirmed we have
as warm and gorgeous cancers of course
being briefed on the public realm works
and the um
stanford quarter work and of course we
don't we don't wait to be briefed as
as richard and others here we'll we'll
confirm where we're forever um
and festering officers for updates so um
yes i'm sure others will hear the
details in due course thanks
thank you council jerome i just wanted
to say quickly um
the incredible work that the bid do in
supporting the town centre
and putting initiatives in place that
really you know generate and revitalize
the town centre so i
just wanted to say a big thank you to
them also thanks leader
that that is um very much the right
point to be making council jerome they
do do
a significant amount of work to promote
to promote the town centre we mustn't
lose
sight of that um i have council limits
young please
um thank you for letting me speak um
counselor weston um
mention has was made i think it was just
now
that um you would be consulting about
the hail peace plan in hail in the
summer
could i just make an appeal not to do
any consultation
in the month of august because that
traditionally is a month
when an awful lot of people in august
go away and we've had this issue before
on the previous time
that the application was made when we
asked could it be deferred
until september not done in august
especially this year
with the end of the hope for the end of
the um
pandemic a lot of people will be going
away in august
and i think it's a particularly bad time
to consult
anywhere in it'll be just the same in
in in hail as well anyway thank you for
letting me speak
that's right i don't know if you want to
come in on that
yeah the points on board council young
thank you for raising it
i think my understanding at this moment
is we're looking at potentially for june
um although that may uh potentially
change but yeah take the point on board
and we will
aim to avoid august for the for the
reasons that you're laid out thank you
thank you councillor right i think
certainly if we
um were to encroach upon august it can
it absolutely cannot be august in
isolation
um and and the only way in which i would
be accepting august is if it was a
significantly
lengthier consultation than than just a
few weeks but as councillor wright said
we will endeavor
to um to avoid that i think
that is all of the questions and
comments
on this item so um the recommendations
are as
per the report can they be agreed
please
you item nine is the corporate
operational estate strategy
which is council right please
thank you leader uh this report sets out
a five year strategy which converts our
approach to our assets from reactive
to proactive and prioritizes services
over buildings
there are six key objectives this
strategy to have a sustainable and fit
for purpose
portfolio of assets to improve
utilization
to reduce maintenance and running costs
to minimize expenditure on private
sector rented accommodation
to support energy efficiency in the
drive for carbon neutrality
and to have clear agreements relating to
any third party occupation of council
space
one of the most important parts of this
report
is the aim to decarbonize buildings and
make them more energy efficient
and sustainable in the short and long
term
you will note the identified buildings
the initial improvements we think can be
made to this in table 1 and table 2 of
the report
you will also note that in july 2020
we reviewed 11 assets under the control
of the council and made a plan for each
which you detail within the report of
course any review of our assets will
need to take into account the effects of
covington 19
on the work habits of many of our staff
many of whom will have become accustomed
to agile working
the strat this strategy formalizes and
streamlines our approach to managing
maintaining and making better use of our
assets
and provides clear guidance and
direction i ask that the executive
approves the report thank you leader
thank you councillor wright any
questions or comments from members of
the
executive no
questions or comments more widely
councillor morgan please
thank you leader um just a couple of
questions um
really um on page 194
um and table one which uh councillor
wright was referring to
the um at page 195 that the application
which was made
and the bid was that outcomes expected
to be in um
january 21 um given the quite tight time
frame for the amount of spend required
if we could just have an update on that
and then the 220 000 um
efficiency on the operational estate
leader that you mentioned earlier
um i was just wondering what um
percentage is that of the total cost
which is expected
and what amount is expected i know it's
i know it's all forecast at the moment
and it's a it's a
process it's expected from reduced cost
versus increases on
um income from the estate thank you
thanks councillor right you want to
answer those as best you can it may be
that we call upon richard
uh yes i can certainly answer the first
question uh we haven't received uh news
of the outcome of the bid
yet um although we have included in the
capital programme
um so i think richard may be able to
update you on
when we're likely to hear about that i'm
certainly going to pass over to richard
for the second question thank you
richard can you shine any light on on
that question around
cost versus income or indeed endeavor to
take it away
and provide that input possible uh yeah
just uh uh for clarification that
savings target is across the whole of
the council the state not just our
operational
um estate and so it will be a
combination of increased
income and reduced cost more efficient
lessons and use of our
buildings and so we don't at the moment
have a specific
split this strategy is focused very much
on our operational state which actually
is a relatively small
section of our overall property holding
um but we'll take that we'll take the
question away so we can see if you can
come back to council market with a bit
more clarity
thank you richard that would be helpful
and councillor copkins
thank you i want to welcome the um the
the funding for the decarbonization of
the
of the public estate um i was wondering
has that actually been confirmed now
last i had heard we were still waiting
for
the final confirmation from salex and
also i'm just wondering um i'd
very much appreciate where it's getting
us to and um and especially that i see
it was the most energy-hungry elements
of the estate that were considered
um i'm just wondering how it fits with
um with our
um need to reduce emissions by 13
percent a year
um i see the um the public sector
decarbonization target is a 50
reduction by 2032 and
our carbon neutral action plan and the
anthesis report is calling for
something like a 70ish percent reduction
by 2027.
so there's still um quite a big gap
between i suppose what
national government is funding and where
we need to actually be
and i'm very much aware that as well
it's not all the council's job to fill
all of that but just wondering where
we're thinking of
and for for next steps and all that
thank you
thank you council covington it's all
right with council right i'll come in on
that with my
portfolio hat on unless he has a burning
contribution to make
um i certainly think that you're right
that it cannot all
fall to the local authority to achieve
those
emissions reductions in and around the
um
the decarbonisation of buildings there
is clearly significant problems that can
be made
as you said but actually it's that
leadership role not
setting an example role in that
convening role that will be
incredibly important in the in the years
ahead but this is a significant step
forward and unless
i'm going to be contradicted by richard
which would be really poor if that is
the case because it is my gm portfolio i
understand that the money has now been
confirmed
um for the 80 million to decarbonize
public buildings
but i will double check that because i
think i may have been told it was
imminent
uh rather than absolutely um confirmed
and
as far as i am aware though if it has
not arrived it is
almost certain to do so um and hence we
set the 4.3
million pound um figure in the capital
spend for
for this year so um so i think i think
significant quick gains there
more work to do for the future you
you've
underscored the challenge that we have
absolutely perfectly there councillor
hoggins which is the very
many of the things that we would like to
do do require national funding
um clearly i am involved in bidding for
funding for the whole of greater
manchester we are not shy when it comes
to making those applications but
alas we're not always successful and
indeed when we are
the um the scale of the funding
available can at times be
deemed slightly less ambitious than we
would have hoped for but it's something
that that we need to to
keep at both in terms of the work that
we do directly but also that convening
and leadership role
um i'm not seeing any other questions or
comments on this so the
um the recommendations are us set out in
the report can they be agreed please
thank you item 10 is the um great
manchester
clean air plan update i'm not going to
go
into considerable detail on this because
um
council have been updated fairly
regularly
on the um on the clean air plan
over recent months there are a number of
things to note on the report itself
in terms of um progress so
specifically around an issue in times
side in and out of
the border with um the high peak and a
range of other
um individual issues for instance the
fact that we started to disseminate bus
retrofit funding back in september what
i do
just want to back in december rather
i'll get that right
um rather than go through all of those
items that are for noting i do
particularly want to draw colleagues
attention to the elements of the report
that
are for an agreement and they
are predominantly surrounding the future
governments
arrangements for when the clean air zone
is
up and running and that is the intention
with the approval of all 10 districts to
establish
two different committees um so firstly
as set out at 9.5 the report a joint
committee of charging
authorities for the decisions that need
to be taken jointly by the 10
authorities themselves um and then
a second committee which would also
include the greater manchester combined
authority
which you may recall from previous
updates is a charging authority
um in terms of how we will move forward
in structuring and administering the
clean air zone and
resultant um charges that
are incurred by um vehicles that are
outside of criteria so
two different committees there and then
with specific reference
to trafford the need to
agree to appoint councillor adset to
serve on both of those committees for
the council i'd ask colleagues to note
that i will be the combined authority
representative
on the relevant committee and therefore
um even though there would normally be a
discussion between councillor and
uh and i on who would be more
appropriate
to serve on that committee because i
will be appointed
via um my green city region lead role
clean airplane lead role um councillor
ted will sit on those committees
representing
trafford um so that's probably all that
i need to say as i said there are a
number of
um items for noting but the substantive
decision surrounds the approval of the
government's
arrangements there's um there are a
couple of delegations there around just
agreeing the final nature of the
specific agreements
um and as we move through contracts etc
but the pertinent points of the report
in terms of how the
clean air zone will function in terms of
our current understanding
on um the consultation are
still very much to follow i know
that executive members will be briefed
on
friday as to the consultation
outcomes and it will obviously be
interesting to hear
from them on um moving forward on what
the
what the outcome of the consultation was
i think there's also
a particular point um to be made
that the work that i commissioned to
look at the
economic impact of covid and how that
would
change potentially the nature of the
support
available for certain sections of the
business community
or self-employed community will also be
wrapped up this week and come before
executive members on
friday and clearly i will
update colleagues after that in my
portfolio role so that people
are aware of the information um that
comes out of that
but in terms of the specific parameters
of this report
it is the items for noting and then the
agreement around both the establishment
the committee structure
and the appointment of counsellor said
are there any questions or comments
from members of the executive
no questions or comments more widely i'm
going to ask councillor coggins again is
that
an old hand or a new hand
sorry it's an old hand i need to get
into the internet no worries
uh councillor evans then please i
suspect you're expected
i'll i'll try and not rerun old
arguments uh
i just have a few prop issues with the
report and really ask
you directly as as the lead member and
and
and possibly even andy burnham as well
to go and argue our case
and there's a section six which
describes the other um areas so
lead sheffield and bristol have ditched
it for various reasons
uh the nearest comparator that i would
argue is probably
birmingham which is introducing one but
i have the
my major issue is to take back and
actually look at the whole thing again
if we can
and theirs is 10 square miles ours is
493
square miles and and then there's
another point
uh which is the minister has written out
to
areas and and boroughs again to say
where necessary and i just don't think
all i see from the gmca or feel is that
i know we're fighting for compensation
and i've just been a look to fans we're
talking about
about 15 to 20 000 pounds per van
for these small businesses which is is
tough
at this point um and where necessary
is 493 square miles it will be the
biggest in the world
and and places like partington and
altringham for that matter and
don't have this pollution but it's going
to impact so
i think there's many arguments there and
and hinged on necessary
and possibly other models and i
appreciate they
they might not be in this part of the
report for noting but seriously somebody
needs to be arguing the case not just to
compensate
but actually is it necessary at 493
square miles we know what the emissions
have been
thank you thank you councillor evans so
in terms of necessity clearly we are
mandated by government policy as it
stands clearly
there have been material changes for
what is modeled to be one year
as a result of the pandemic however all
projections show that it is anticipated
that we will return to having areas of
exceedance
in all ten boroughs um this year that
therefore in my view
does suggest that the um zone would be
necessary moving forward obviously it is
only for a limited period because it is
anticipated that we would
achieve compliance and then indeed
vehicle fleet would change in such a way
that it would not be
needed in for instance you know five or
six years time potentially however
in terms of the size and scale
of the scheme i i mean i have to say
direct comparisons with birmingham are
difficult they are very very different
projects
um and you know i i can't remember
offhand actually the particulars of the
birmingham scheme but i suspect within
the 10 mile zone it may well be rather
more severe
than ours is i'm not convinced that it
is the largest zone in the world
um indeed i think it's probably the
largest outside of london in this
country
um but the um you know that
i think the challenge that we face here
is the
is the need to accept and i do
particularly following the judgment of
um a coroner
late last year into the death of ella
kissy deborah
a nine-year-old down in london that it
is the poorest
kids that breed the poorest air there is
a compelling public health case as well
as environmental place to act that i
personally do accept that said you are
right there will be
an impact on business and i am lobbying
quite hard
to meet with ministers to discuss both
um the question of the financial support
package
moving forward um in general but also
the covid support um impact specifically
in terms of how that we
will have materially changed the offer i
think the challenge with
saying go back and say no because other
areas such as leeds and bristol
have gone back and said no is that they
were at different stages of the process
so leads had already begun to
disseminate funding
which has allowed them to secure
compliance through the funding that was
already made available we're not in that
position
clearly we were at pre-consultation
stage when the pandemic hits we've not
been able to therefore have the impact
as yet that leads this scheme had
happened at the poor the buildup deleted
scheme
has had um meaning that it was no longer
deemed necessary there all i can say
um very clearly on this is that the
government
have consistently told us that this
needs to go ahead and
on the basis that the modeling that we
have indicates that the problem has only
gone away
very temporarily and i am compelled
by the evidence there and the position
of ministers that this
is still necessary and that the scheme
that we're bringing forward will be
required but i can see you want to ask a
further question nathan's uh councillor
evans
thank you thank you for uh and saying it
taking these questions
and the other question is where can we
actually we have our
skirmishes for one of the better phrase
at these meetings
uh where can we actually scrutinize this
because they go to gmca
and they say it's at borough level and
so that
i have not experienced or seen an actual
proper scrutiny where people
i i say to you as we've said now and you
come back
with with answers but it's not proper
scrutiny
um is it at gmca through through the
three scrutinies
or is it our borough level and we need
to
try and get it and put call it into
scrutiny here and say this is the impact
it's going to have on our
trafford businesses what are we going to
do about it
so far be it for me to um advise members
on how they should and shouldn't use the
scrutiny process it would be
local arrangements because it is the
individual
boroughs who have come together to
create the clean air
plan in response to the government
director
direction and therefore it would be an
item that you may wish
to um table at the scrutiny um
subject of course for the usual um
procedures but yes i have attended
a greater manchester scrutiny session on
this but purely as a
for information and out of politeness um
really on that on that basis because it
is not
um something that falls within the
jurisdiction of greater manchester
scrutiny so it would be
local arrangements thank you council on
this blackburn please
thank you leader could have
clarification on just
two points please um point three
points sorry three point eleven uh
outline business case for the
local vehicle scrappage stroke
grade measures um can you confirm um
what the timeline is for the business
case to be completed
so we are we we need to
have the outcome of the public
consultation readily available to us
before we can do that but my
understanding is that we're anticipating
putting in
the outline business case over the
summer there are
there is in the um recommendations at
the start of the report
a specific um a specific
piece there around summer 2021 on the
decisions that need to
um be made and i as far as i'm aware but
i will double check
and confirm to you by email councilman
blackburn i'm i i think we're working
towards the summer
right and just the other one um 6.4.1
um it's regarding um asking the
government to tackle the
nitrogen dioxide exceededness which is a
horrible word
um on the strategic road network could
have just asked what kind of contact has
been made
and what's been the outcome of the
contact so
over the past um it would be remiss of
me not
to acknowledge the previous portfolio
holder's role in this so over the past
at least
four years multiple representations have
been made both
by politicians directly in person and in
writing but also
by transport for greater manchester and
greater manchester combined authority
officers
to the joint air quality unit um to
ask them to recognize the fact that the
most polluting roads
are in fact the motorways um they fall
outside of scope
for the clean air plan and if you
consider
um the areas of exceedance within
greater manchester and look at them on a
map
it doesn't take a genius to work out but
the motorways are a significant part of
the problem if you think about our
primary area of exceedance here in
trafford it's where the m60 meets the
856
between sale and stratford so um we have
consistently made the case um we've
we've also mentioned it not that i think
for a minute either ministers or members
of jack who are sat watching greater
manchester combined authority meetings
but as regularly as possible in that
forum as well and we have had mps raise
the issue
in parliament and i suspect i'm rightly
saying on a cross-party basis
on that as well um that but certainly
multiple greater manchester mps have
raised the issue
with ministers okay thank you thanks
um i'm not seeing any other um
hands on this one so there are a series
of recommendations mainly for noting
along with the specific
um proposals around um the appointment
of council rats head and the
establishment of the two committees can
they be agreed please
thank you item eleven is the corporate
plan quarter three four twenty twenty
one councillor freeman please
thank you leader the the report provides
a summary performance against the
council's corporate plan 2021 supporting
management information for the period
the 1st of october 2020 to the 31st of
december 2020.
the plan reports key performance
indicators and activity against the
seven corporate priorities for the
period 2019
to 2022 there are many wide ranging
existing shortages and programs of work
that underpin the corporate plan
we've discussed two of them tonight
already the economy recovery plan
and the pro and the recovery program
activity
and all of these work together to
deliver for the benefit of residents of
business in trafford
this quarter's performance has continued
to be a mix of having to deal with the
continued effects
of kobe 19 while simultaneously continue
to
continue our recovery plan to build back
better
a summary of the quarter 3 20 20 out
turn is produced in the table
where the performance is rag rated it is
pleasing to note that for this quarter
there are no exception reports for
missed targets
finally during 2021 we do intend to
review our strategic priorities to
ensure
the corporate plan takes cognizance
of digital skills green space carbon
neutrality
and sustainability and that current
strategies supporting our recovery
program e.g the poverty strategy
equality strategy are taking account of
executive for us to note the report
thank you leader
thank you councillor freeman any
questions or comments from members of
the executive
on this now any questions or comments
more widely
no okay the recommendations are as
set out in the report can they be agreed
please
item 12 is urgent business and unusually
i have an extremely urgent
piece of business because having thought
that she got away with it at council
last week it's also worth noting that
this is nikki's last executive
um so just on behalf of the executive
and i'm sure everybody else who is on
the call
and all of the wonderful things that you
were said about you
that we said about you last wednesday
nikki just to assure you that we really
do believe them
and we're all very irked by the fact
that you are
retiring however we know that graham
will do a brilliant job for us we wish
you
all the very best um with your
retirement and just
um with a specific executive functions
hat on thank you
very much for what has been some of the
soundest advice that we could have
received over the past
few years and indeed the way in which
you've always been
very open with with all members on these
calls and and
indeed when we were physically meeting i
can remember as leader of the opposition
and routinely asking questions around
financial matters and indeed other
matters
um where you as the font of all
knowledge would come in
and make sure that we were usually
corrected and set straight
but i would say um to be more generous
to myself
uh happy with the answers provided so um
just just a huge thank you from all of
us nikki
and and all the very best for the future
i um i had thought that um march may be
your last executive meeting but i
i realized that you are using some
holiday um
at the end of your um at the end of
next month to allow you to scoot off a
little earlier
than your than your final date so um i
don't think that we need to
have um multiple members come in because
a lot was said
on um on wednesday by the group leaders
i did just wonder if tom did want to say
anything and it's totally fine if not
because i realize i'm putting them on
the spot
past the ross it's always a pleasure to
thank nikki for her time at the council
and again as
you said andrew both in opposition and
in in control the advice that nikki has
provided to us all has been sound
has been robust and it does genuinely
help us run
this council better so nikki enjoy your
early very early retirement and i hope
from what i hear you
from last week you like walking i hope
you find lots and lots of lovely walking
groups there's a fair few in stratfor
that i'm very used to now so you might
want
to check them out but all the very best
nikki we will miss
you and we know that um you're leaving
it in very safe hands with graham
thanks um councillor ross okay so
that does bring us um to
an end for tonight's meeting massive
thank you
to um everybody for their attendance
and i'm sure nikki will open something
to do with the alcoholic now to
celebrate the fact that she's never got
this
uh not got to be effective but
um on that on that happy and cheery note
uh for nikki um i wish everybody
a very good night and i will see you all
soon take care
bye